hello me from 10 years ago I recently
received the Facebook reminder that you
just met David Attenborough almost
exactly 10 years ago during the first
couple of weeks as an undergrad at
Oxford to answer your immediate question
yes he is still alive
but no you haven't met him again since
there you have met a bunch of other
interesting people that you never
thought you'd ever meet Tom Hanks was
really nice the next 10 years are full
of surprises for you but also problems
and so I thought it's sending this
message to try and prepare you for those
problems and hopefully save you some
time in learning a couple of important
lessons now I know what you're thinking
but the butterfly effect by telling me
this information now you're eliminating
the possibility of the future which
you're describing you're rendering this
whole exercise pointless there are no
such thing as spoilers well yes but I
hate to break it to you but you're not
me you're an audience on YouTube and
this isn't a personal message it's a
video designed to be watched by tens of
thousands of people possibly the
strangest thing
that will happen to you in the next 10
years is that you will very soon
actually in the next couple of weeks
make a YouTube channel and upload a
video talking about applying to Oxford
as a state school student and that video
does quite well so you make some more
and you like making videos eventually
you even vlog your final year at Oxford
and then go on to make more and more
videos and eventually you accumulate
over 10 million views you have an
international audience of hundreds of
thousands of people unfortunately you do
get stuck with a very dumb name that you
literally just pick on the spot in the
Oxford computing department like pick a
better name but your names this video is
one that you will design in about ten
years time partly to celebrate ten years
of being on YouTube but also to deliver
some important news and also to make
some meta points on the nature of
reflection and YouTube in an attempt to
live up to the perceived personality and
associated ethics that your online
persona is accumulated over the years
like rings on a tree you're not thinking
about YouTube a lot by the way so in the
next 10 years you become a youtuber much
like the YouTube is the old watching
right now
some of them have moved on to other
things but some of them are actually
still around some of them are your peers
if your friends even and you could be
considered to have become the person
that you wanted to be you are a
successful youtuber you make videos that
people watch all over the world
you're even recognized in the street
sometimes you have famous friends you
know you're successful not rich though
that's um that hasn't happened yet
you're also a doctor by the way you do
your PhD in a field that you don't even
know exists yet you'll get to it in
third year I wouldn't ruin that surprise
but um spoilers you start calling
yourself a scientist at some point
because if you do original research you
travel around the world presenting that
work you know you have in another way
you become the person that you always
wanted to be so why are we making this
video then you know us we're not the
kind of person who boasts about their
accomplishments or indeed has any kind
of positive self-image
well you become the person that you want
it to be scientists filmmaker ubasti you
can run your own business the problem is
that now ten years down the line you're
not the person that you wants to be over
the next ten years and particularly
after you finish your PhD you notice
that things aren't quite right you can't
put your finger on it but you you feel
like something is just wrong it's almost
like you're singing in a choir and
you're singing the right notes but at a
different tempo to everyone else you're
getting increasingly out of time you
sing now
by the way quite a lot you started to
impress a girl
and anyway because of how you are you're
not very good at talking about your
emotions or even really knowing what
emotion you're feeling any given time
so this Fester's longer than most people
would let it it'll start when you're at
Oxford and you are working all the time
in an attempt to prove yourself by doing
well and not taking any time to relax or
socialize even and so you will get
completely exhausted and you won't do as
well academically as you think
you should and that frustration will
eventually turn into a burning
self-hatred some stuff will happen in
your fourth year at Oxford which will
make all of this much much worse and you
will eventually reach a point where you
are broken and this will compelled into
profound impostor syndrome whilst you're
doing your PhD and then recently for me
in about ten years for you things will
come to a head and you will have a
moment of clarity that you are and have
been for some time quite profoundly
unwell you're not a doctor
what if you are but not a useful medical
doctor so you can't self diagnose but
you are pretty sure that you are
depressed constantly anxious and most
crippling lis of all have a complete
lack of confidence in anything that you
do anymore
much of this will stem from how you will
continue to overwork yourself and have
unrealistic expectations of how much
work you could and it should be doing
being a youtuber by choice you have an
additional constant pressure to maintain
relevance on different social media
channels and to bring in revenue one of
which is dependent on the other and
that's a constant force on your back
this is complicated by the fact that
being a youtuber you will be the product
that you will be selling and so you have
to be market ready at all times and even
if things aren't going very well you
have to pretend that everything is and
so that's an additional strain this this
strain to pretend that everything's fine
all times and then the extra strain of
fear of being found out that you are
selling a product that is not what it
claims to be you leave it right about
this point of self commoditization and
it will get brought up by Tom Scott in a
lecture at the Royal Institution you
know your name in the famous lecture
theatre and yet despite this despite
being a successful youtuber despite
earning a PhD you will have zero
confidence in anything that you are
doing or saying you will think that
nobody should listen to you or pay any
attention to the stuff that you are
doing you will feel incapable of doing
anything and that lack of confidence
will shrink your life and limit any form
of self-expression eventually and you
will feel incapable of making anything
incapable therefore of bringing in any
money and it will make you feel like
there's no real way forward I hate to
say it but these are the things which
are going to happen to you over the next
ten years in this timeline because you
don't have to live through these events
I'm here delivering this message to you
to tell you what I'm going to do now and
what I want you to do over the next 10
years to fix these problems first of all
get all of this out in the open I've
actually already done this I wrote a
blog post which I'll come back to in
just a minute but for your sake talk
about how you are feeling not constantly
because you don't know sound like an
Instagram influencer but hang on was
Instagram I think 10 years ago
no that was founded in 2010 so you have
that hellscape of narcissism to look
forward to the point is be honest about
how you are feeling and talk to the
people you care about the people who
care about you
because even if it doesn't feel that way
there are people who care about you your
parents your your family your friends
your partner be honest about how you're
feeling it and talk it out when you're
not feeling okay but secondly understand
that you cannot work for 13 or 14 hours
a day every day
a for longer than a month or two life
isn't a sprint it's a marathon and so
you have to invest time in your own
well-being ring-fence time that is just
for you
you can view yourself as a product that
needs time for development if you like
or just as a human being with needs and
wants and desires beyond just adding
economic value to the wider world go
running you actually end up quite liking
running keep painting Warhammer in my
timeline you take me ten years out of
the hobby but you get back into it and
you still bloody love these lumps of
plastic crack life is too short to do
anything other than what you are
passionate about and economic work can
be one of those things but it shouldn't
be all of them thirdly when things get
bad get help when you're at university
and you don't think that the mental
health services are for people like you
they are when you've left University and
you don't think the your mental state is
important enough to go to the doctor's
et's yes these mental health services
are not perfect and yes they will be
used by people in cases far more severe
than yours but they would still want to
hear from you because they are meant for
people like you to getting help takes a
huge amount of courage because often it
involves unearthing trauma that you have
buried I know for a fact that I still
have to work through a lot of stuff that
happened to me in my fourth year at
Oxford and being honest with myself and
my family and friends about that was one
of the hardest things I've ever done but
I know that it will be worth the
investment because by getting help now I
am improving hopefully the rest of my
life to that end I will be dialing back
the frequency that I'm gonna be
uploading stuff to this channel you the
audience now I mean may have noticed I
haven't uploaded for quite a while
anyway
and that's because I've been doing all
of the above and it's gonna take weeks
it's probably gonna take months even but
I hope to
be back here uploading maybe our weekly
but certainly regularly and hopefully
also making podcast on the wiki cast and
streaming on Twitch just give me a bit
of time for me I've already made a bunch
of changes to my work-life balance and
going forward I know there are further
changes I would like to make on this
channel such as outsourcing a lot of my
editing it's an investment but I'm
hoping that that investment will allow
me to make better videos more regularly
most importantly more healthily lastly I
just where's a touch on why I hadn't
made this video until now because like I
said I made a blog post a while back now
which is the you know link in the
description you can read it if you want
there's more details on everything I've
talked about but the reason I did it
this way is because I think on YouTube
there is a tendency to make videos about
mental health and about a very honest
desire to improve oneself in a way which
almost commoditize --is suffering it
commoditize --is the discussion of
mental health it's kind of a genre all
on its own and I think in a funny way I
value my YouTube audio so value you guys
too much to allow you to find out about
a topic as serious as this via a YouTube
video and so the people who you know
care about my well-being who follow me
on social media or whatever
you can find out about this stuff on
social media on my website what have you
but at the same time I think it'd be
inappropriate to not make a video
talking about this because this YouTube
channel is the hub of my existence
online it's the the nexus of everything
that I do so I thought it'd be
inappropriate to not make a video about
this I just want to try and do it in a
way which resisted a lot of the tropes
of if you like this genre this video
also falls are very neat
time to celebrate my 10 year anniversary
on YouTube although it does feel a
little bit disingenuous to be
celebrating 10 years on the platform
which has exacerbated most of the mental
health issues that I've been suffering
from but I would be remiss to not say a
colossal
thank you to you the audience because
much as this platform and this career
has its own issues which are entirely
self-inflicted in which I'm trying to
work through I recognize I am incredibly
lucky to have this nuts career and the
amazing opportunities that I've had
recently so more generally I guess than
I've ever said in at the end of a video
before thank you so much for watching if
this video has resonated with you in any
way please do heed my advice you know
talk about how you are feeling be honest
with yourself and if necessary get help
there's nothing wrong with getting help
and a great deal that's right and if
you'd like to learn more about the
situation that I'm in then yeah link in
the description of the blog post it's a
much more appropriate mechanism I think
of talking about issues like this rather
than a YouTube video he says the YouTube
communicator I'll be back hopefully
before too long with some fresh new
content and maybe even a fresh new look
it's pretty about time to spring clean
the place but most importantly a
healthier attitude and a healthier
work-life balance because I deserve it
and I deserve to believe in myself thank
you very much for watching oh and one
more thing for me ten years ago Bitcoin
you